mix it real good describe the moment you
got the green light for your talks okay
where were you what was a reaction I was
in my office I was sitting on my sofa
and I had this just feeling of like oh
this is absolutely 100% not real you
know I never actually dreamt of it and
what was it presented to me I was head
over heels in love with the idea because
if it even come true and I didn't have a
dream of because my brain is not that
creative self when real life is better
than your dreams inside the latest issue
of The Hollywood Reporter the Ontario
native opens up about adjusting to Fame
including her decision to take a break
from creating content last November I am
mentally physically emotionally and
spiritually exhausted reflecting on the
break
Lily tells the magazine I turned into
such a machine I was feeling that I was
completely losing what it means to be
human
during her month-long hiatus Lily sought
a therapist and began meditating and
shortly after she publicly came out as
bisexual it's not that I had this big
secret because of the culture I was
raised in I never actually allowed
myself to figure things out moving to LA
I was exposed to so many different types
of people and I think that probably
opened up my horizons now the 30 year
old is hard at work hearing up for a
little late with Lilly Singh premiere on
global September 16th which will make
her the first woman of colour to host a
late-night show on a major network and
while the new gig will certainly keep
her busy
Lily currently has no plans to stop
making videos for her superwoman YouTube
channel but she does want to embrace her
new identity saying when I created my
YouTube channel I was like copy
superwoman more and more I would like to
call myself Lilly
[Music]